-It's always great to see you.
But I told you we were
going to get that win, right?
-I feel so, like...
-Yes, you -- We did it.
We got it.
-...invincible.
-Yes! Come on! We crushed it!
-Invincible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew we would be
good together.
Thanks for coming back
to the show.
You know, there's a big debate
always around this time.
Is it too early to get ready
for Christmas?
Can you listen to the music?
Can you decorate?
And you say --
-I say it's not too early to
start on Halloween.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, I mean, is that when
you start, around Halloween?
No.
-Well, I pull the tree out.
And, I mean, it's --
Mine is out.
I haven't decorated it.
I'm doing that when I get back.
-Oh, yeah.
So, the -- But the tree is out.
Is it -- is it plugged --
-It's lit and plugged in,
but no decorations, guys.
-Yeah. Now, do you do --
Do you do a real tree?
-No, no, no.
-Fake tree.
-I like the fake tree
because you have
the lights evenly distributed.
-Wow!
-Otherwise, you'll have pockets,
you know, that are just...
-Do you have the whole family --
Do you have every --
Do you host everyone
for the holidays?
-No.
I usually go home
because it's easier for me,
but -- and, in all honesty,
nobody in my life
would ever want me
to host a party or...
-I think you would be
a great host.
-Well, only because --
And I just want to see
if you guys agree
and if you agree.
I have -- I tap out early.
So I'm ready to be done before
other people are,
and if --
-No, no, no, no, no.
-If you're hosting,
you can't go,
"Ooh, guys, you know,
dinner is from 8:00 to 10:00.
It's 9:30."
-You've got to go to
10:00 at least.
-Yes.
I just -- So --
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-No, yeah. Then you can't.
But have you ever tried it?
-"Dinner is from 8:00 to 10:00.
It's 9:30."
I am going to try next year.
-Yeah. Oh, you will?
-I am. Yeah.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah.
-So then, after next year,
I want you to come back
on the show to discuss
how it went.
-I can tell you,
I'm going to be really panicked.
-Around 9:30, how do we get
the family up politely?
-How do we get them out?
How do we get them out? Yeah.
-I want to talk to you
about this,
because you told me
a very funny story,
and you brought a photo,
as well.
It's Halloween,
and you were getting some candy.
-Yeah.
-Getting ready for Halloween.
And -- Well, do we --
-Well, so, here's the thing.
I never have cash with me.
And I was all excited.
I'm also that customer
who's, like, ready.
I don't want to be fumbling for
my cash or my credit card
when I'm at the register.
-Me neither.
-So I like to find it.
I'm like, "Do I have cash?"
Like, "Do I have $5?"
And I found a $100 bill
in my wallet.
And I was so proud because
I felt like I had
found a treasure.
And, so, I'm glad
I'm one of those people
who likes to be prepared,
because I'm looking at the
$100 bill and I'm like,
"Ben Franklin looks
really, really weird."
-Yeah.
And this is the -- This is what
you gave the person at the --
at the store.
-I realized...
I realized it was
a prop from "Spirited"
and I almost paid with it.
Can you imagine?
-Counterfeit
Ryan Reynolds money.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
You almost went to jail.
-I almost went to jail.
-You almost went to prison
over Ryan Reynolds.
How did you end up with this?
What is this?
-Well, it's a prop from the set,
and I saw it on the floor
and I thought, "Wow, that's a
great -- It looks real."
And I thought, because I never
have money in my wallet,
that I would remember.
We shot it a year ago.
This just happened Halloween.
-Yeah.
That's so funny.
But now is it out of
your purse and safe?
-I have it on a shelf.
I save props and things
from sets.
So I have it on my bookshelf.
And I'm never saving money
from any other set.
-Yeah, there you go.
You learned your lesson.
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about "Spirited."
Congratulations on this.
You know, I...
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a big, fun
comedy, holiday musical.
Can we set up what it's about?
-Yes.
It's a retelling
of "A Christmas Carol,"
but it's from
the ghosts' perspective.
-Which I think is brilliant.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so,
Will Ferrell is actually
looking at his past and going,
"Why am I doing this?
Why am I finding
a Scrooge every year?
What's the point of all this?"
Yeah.
-Yes.
-Last time you were on our show,
you were just about to
start filming.
and you were very excited but
also a little nervous,
because the director asked you
if you ice-skate.
-If I ice-skate.
And I immediately said,
"Uh, no."
And so they got me
this world-class trainer,
Elladj Baldé, from Canada.
And that --
-I should say this is a photo.
This is not the trainer,
Elladj Baldé.
This is you and
a plastic seal for children.
That is for --
usually for children
to learn how to ice-skate.
But this is before you
got the training.
-Before I got the training.
-Yeah. And you were nervous.
-I was --
-But we showed this on the show,
and I appreciate you being
so, well, confident.
-But here's the thing.
I realized that
I could master the ice.
-Yes.
-I did.
-Conquered your demons.
And we have a clip.
We'll see how it ended up going.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Here's Octavia Spencer.
Watch this.
What? Didn't fall down?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I did not fall down.
I did learn
how to be on the ice.
-Uh-huh.
-But I called it "ice scooting."
-Were you --
-I wasn't wearing...
-Skates.
-...the skates.
No, I --
-Right there.
-Yeah. No, I just decided
I could scoot on
if I had my sneakers.
-You ice-acted? You skate-acted?
-Well, the director was like,
"Don't do that.
Nobody does that."
It's like driving
and doing this.
So I was like, "Oh, I guess I
probably --" Yeah.
So I didn't.
-But you sing also in this.
This is a lot of pressure for
you to do a lot of stuff.
-There were a lot of new things,
a lot of moving parts.
So I --
-Academy Award winner.
You got to do it all now.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
They expect it from you.
-Yeah.
-But you sound phenomenal.
-Well, thank you, but
it took a lot to get me there,
because I had no idea
what it takes to do a musical,
because --
Well, here's the thing.
We all sing every day.
I don't consider myself
a singer.
But I thought I could
probably do it,
because, you know, when you're
singing with the radio,
you sound so good, right?
You're like...
-Yeah, I might
roll down the windows.
I sound pretty good.
I want people to hear this one.
Yeah.
-You know, you hit the notes.
But you realize that
you're singing very low, like...
♪ Hello ♪
-Ooh.
-You know, it's --
-♪ Is it me
you're looking for? ♪
-Wow. That was magic.
-It was magic.
And then I realized, you know,
they were going to
have a microphone, so I thought
I would just use my little --
my radio singing voice.
And it's kind of small,
like a little mouse voice.
And the music --
the voice coach, Eric Vetro,
was like, "Yeah, I'm going to --
I'm going to need you to
sing out."
-Project, yeah.
-Yeah, project.
-You got to project
a little bit.
Yeah, this movie is not
a text message,
so we need to hear you.
-And I literally
started panicking,
because I thought, "Well,
what have I signed on to do?"
I thought I was going to walk
around, you know...
♪ Singing mouse voice ♪
-You crushed it.
-Thank you.
-And you're singing with Will,
with Will Ferrell.
-Well, then he
makes it easier, though.
-Yeah, he's fun.
-So, we have a musical director
who taught me
how to use the lyrics
to the song as a monologue.
Now, that I understand, but...
♪ Singing in mouse voice ♪
-No, I think you have it.
You sound so great.
And it's very funny
and it's very holiday
and it puts you in a good mood,
in a good spirit.
You do get in
the holiday spirit.
-You do.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Octavia Spencer
in "Spirited."
Take a look.
-Hey!
[ Chuckles ]
You're back and in
a-a boldly tight suit.
-Yeah, it -- it is
a little snug.
-No, I-I like it.
It's kind of a Euro fit.
-Oh.
-And I like it on you.
-Yeah. Yeah, it is a Euro fit,
because I buy all my clothes
in Germany.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-I can see.
-Um, uh, sorry.
But would you -- would you want
to, uh, go somewhere
and maybe -- I don't -- No.
-No, I --
-You don't even have to answer.
-Yeah. I would love to.
-Oh, great. Really?
-Totally. I love somewhere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"I love somewhere."
-It's my favorite place.
-Me too. Octavia Spencer.
"Spirited"
is in theaters this Friday
and on Apple TV+,
globally, November 18th.
We'll be right back with
Matthias Schweighoefer.
Stick around, everybody.